[Musique]
notre CR ce soir Jean Martin un sang
Jean-Luc Landry messieurs merci d'être
là bonne année 2023 alors heureuse de
vous retrouver pour parler de ce dossier
qui éclipse à peu près tous les autres
jusqu'à maintenant cette semaine départ
surprise disons-le entre guillemets de
sophie Brochu à la tête de Diderot
Québec en plus du fait qu'il y aura des
peurs il faut le rappeler de la
présidente du conseil d'administration
est-ce que c'est l'occasion pour le
gouvernement de faire un peu table rase
et d'imposer ses idées qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez Jean-Martin
la présidence du Conseil et le PDG
imposer ses idées je sais pas si c'est
l'objectif j'espère que non parce que si
on va chercher des gens en compétent
pour gérer une société d'État on espère
qu'ils amènent leur temps à leurs idées
mais ce serait pas le même stage puis en
fait j'espère qu'ils vont commencer par
la présidence du Conseil parce que
normalement le rôle d'un conseil
d'administration c'est de choisir et de
superviser le PDG donc ce serait logique
qui est face avec la présidence en
premier oui et c'est un gros morceau
comme vous le mentionnez lorsqu'on doit
passer deux autres dirigeants d'une
société d'État avec un impact économique
aussi important
à quoi est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre
Jean-Luc est-ce que vous vous attendez à
ce que tout se déroule très rondement
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a déjà une idée
de qui pourrait remplacer ce fibreuses
la première des choses là le
gouvernement devrait abolir son fameux
comité qui veut diriger
une société alors qu'ils vont être
chapeauter par un conseil
d'administration et par dessus un autre
comité un ministre c'est une société
d'État on le fait comme ça on a une
rigide de l'électricité on a toutes nos
institutions sont bien structurées et
moi honnêtement je lave le gouvernement
d'avoir joué là-dedans monsieur parce
que
on n'a pas parlé beaucoup laissez faire
ce comité-là n'a pas de bon ça moi
j'étais membre du conseil
d'administration de l'Hydro-Québec après
la formation de ce comité-là j'avais
démissionné pourquoi est-ce que je vais
te conseille d'administration
pourtant sophie Brochu Jean-Luc l'avait
en quelque sorte demandé ce comité-là
parce que l'intervention monsieur fait
skiping faisait que il y avait un clash
entre les visions des deux alors et le
gouvernement on oublie une chose là on
répète toujours que le gouvernement et
l'actionnaire c'est pas vrai c'est le
Québec les Québécois qui sont
actionnaires le gouvernement est un
mandataire temporaire pour 80
Hydro-Québec fait des investissements de
25 ans alors et il y a pas d'affaires à
les dire à tout le monde comment ça
fonctionne un ministre arrive de traiter
l'Hydro-Québec comme un ministère je
pense que l'idée du comité j'entends ce
que tu dis mais l'idée du comité c'était
d'élargir à juste plus que juste la
production d'électricité parce que
Hydro-Québec est une pièce maîtresse
dans le virage écologique et des
communautés autochtones impliquées des
collectivités autre aussi donc c'était
s'assurer peut-être que tout le monde
soit entendu donc
pouvoir à la direction le Québec au
point où ça devient difficile à gérer
est-ce qu'on a plus assez de coups de
franges pour est-ce qu'on a plus assez
la voile libre finalement
oublier et non imposer ses vues aussi et
consultatif le Premier ministre pas que
ça donne rien de l'avoir et là vous vous
engager quelqu'un qui va être une
marionnette du ministre mais c'est la
mise en garde qu'on fait certains oui
comme par exemple aujourd'hui ce que
vous croyez que c'est ça qui va se
passer
en disant pourquoi je vais là je perds
ma réputation en arrivant parce que je
pense pour quelqu'un qui va se
marionnette d'un ministre alors et donc
on parle la possibilité de bons
candidats à cause de ce qui est arrivé
moi j'ai l'impression que Madame brochet
a essayé d'abriller ça mais il y a
personne qui le jupe elle essayait de
pas faire trop de dommages
elle a voulu mettre de côté l'idée que
c'était des tensions politiques ou des
conflits qui auraient mené à tout ça et
d'ailleurs je vous laisse entendre un
extrait de Pierre fitzguiben aujourd'hui
qui comme François Legault d'ailleurs a
dit non non oui il y en a pas eu de
pression il y a pas eu de conflits on
l'écoute
non
[Musique]
octobre donc on a eu quoi cette semaine
d'interaction les mois on a eu plusieurs
rencontres c'était très cordiales très
bien moi je pense pas qu'il y a un jeu
de personnel
est-ce que vous y croyez ça Jean-Martin
on ne saura jamais j'étais pas dans leur
recette rencontre communes mais c'est
rapide parce que trois ans donc je pense
pas que c'est juste qui était tanné où
il y a peut-être autre chose que nous
annoncera bientôt mais c'est ça
m'étonnerait qu'il y ait pas eu la
moindre réflexion
alors on n'est pas tout seul
chose certaine aujourd'hui bon en fait
on a l'impression que une des pressions
ou un des conflits une vision différente
qui avait sophie Brochu de vouloir
mettre l'accent sur la décarbonation du
Québec et la transition énergétique
d'abord vision du gouvernement qui elle
était plutôt de d'utiliser Hydro-Québec
comme outil de développement pour
attirer des projets industriels François
Legault aujourd'hui a été questionné
là-dessus disant non non on va pas
devenir le dolorama de l'énergie mais on
va quand même se servir d'Hydro-Québec
pour combler les quarts de richesse avec
l'Ontario je vous
jamais été question que le Québec soit
le Dollarama par contre
il y a une opportunité comme je le
disais tantôt il faut regarder le
portrait global c'est-à-dire quand on a
un projet devant nous oui il y a une
opportunité pour Hydro-Québec d'avoir un
client additionnel mais il y a une
opportunité aussi de créer de la
richesse d'amener des revenus
additionnels au ministère du Revenu donc
on le sait on a un écart de richesse ça
reste mon obsession
voilà la question qu'on se pose est-ce
que c'est contradictoires
dans la même phrase dire je veux pas
m'en servir comme d'un Dollarama de
l'énergie mais je veux m'en servir pour
attirer des projets
tout à fait naturel en énergie au Québec
il faut s'en servir ceci dit il faut que
ce soit bon prix parce que moi je me
souviens quand j'étais à l'Assemblée
nationale il y avait un rapport assez
qui avait beaucoup de bruit du
vérificateur général à l'époque qui
montrait que certaines compagnies
minières recevent le plus en crédit
d'impôts qu'elle ne payait un redevance
donc on les payait pour venir chercher
nos ressources ce sera pas le cas avec
Hydro-Québec mais j'espère qu'on va
profiter parce qu'on est cet avantage là
par rapport aux autres nations ça doit
devenir un outil d'attraction Jean-Luc à
tout prix je peux me permettre une
comparaison j'avais vu une étude qui
comparait la production d'aluminium en
Chine et au Québec et la grande
différence c'est quoi
l'électricité coûte pas cher au Québec
les salaires sont élevés en Chine
l'électricité couchage les salaires sont
plus bas en d'autres termes les
Québécois subventionnent les salaires
qui des gens de l'aluminium ces
interventions là sont pas des
interventions efficaces dernier petit
point là augmente et quoi on est au
plein d'emploi au Québec
le niveau de vie augmente avec la
productivité pauvre en faisant des deals
pour vendre des affaires bon en tout cas
il semble y avoir un envie de la part du
gouvernement logo de d'inclure les
parties d'opposition dans une grande
réflexion sur l'électrification est-ce
que vous croyez à cette ouverture-là il
faut y croire ça pas de sens qu'un
gouvernement fasse tout ce qu'il veut
c'est écouter personne si l'intérêt
collectif guide un gouvernement toutes
les bonnes idées devraient être retenues
même si elles viennent de notre groupe
parlementaire on verra ce qui va arriver
parce que il y a la réelle politique
dans tout ça et puis les gains
électoraux et des sondages et tout ça
mais j'espère qu'il va écouter tout le
monde bon là la question qui évidemment
tout le monde se pose c'est qui va
remplacer Sophie rocheux d'ailleurs je
me rappelle Jean-Luc dans notre CA des
fêtes vous aviez choisi Sophie brochure
comme la personnalité de l'année on a
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup d'éloges
à son endroit depuis depuis l'annonce de
son départ et qu'est-ce qui est là comme
leader que d'autres n'ont pas qui fait
l'envie
elle vient de service public première
des choses son réflexe à elle c'est un
réflexe de personnes de service public
par opposition par exemple une personne
en compétition là qui dit il faut se
battre mon adversaire etc elle a
toujours pris la langue c'est naturel
chez elle parce que à travailler chez
Énergie à l'avant donc si tu as tout le
temps essayons de faire un service
public efficace et je pense que c'est
réflex là les gens sentent sentaient que
c'est comme ça qu'elle parle il la croit
et que doit avoir est-ce que le son ou
sa successeur doit avoir le même genre
de caractéristiques qui vers qui
devrait-on se tourner
si c'est un gars semble-t-il qu'il faut
qu'il s'appelle Eric parce que Eric
Martel Eric Lachance Eric Fillon mais je
pense que Madame Brochu effectivement
elle a eu des élèves de partout parce
que les méritait ceci dit un ou une PDG
n'est jamais meilleure que son équipe
puis je pense qu'elle serait la première
reconnaître qui était bien épaulé
effectivement on a beaucoup insisté là
dessus effectivement sur la force moi je
regarderai à l'intérieur des services
publics sur tout là parce que il y a une
façon de ce quelqu'un qui est déjà
peut-être en fait le plus simple qui est
déjà à dire au Québec et on pourrait
régler le problème assez rapidement et
même au-delà on a l'impression que quand
on cherche quelqu'un à l'interne c'est
pour un intérêt mais qu'on se tourne
vers l'externe pour confier le plein
mandat est-ce que ça devrait encore être
justement on devrait pas faire l'inverse
oui et se servir justement de gens qui
ont qui sont là qui sont à l'intérieur
les changements énergétiques qu'on va
avoir là l'électricité là c'est
extrêmement complexe pour allumer vos
lumières les tenir allumé tout le temps
là il y a tellement de décisions qui
sont prises avant que la lumière arrive
chez vous le l'électricité c'est
incroyable et là on veut tout changer ce
système là au complet alors quelqu'un de
l'extérieur ça va y prendre combien de
temps avant d'avoir une idée complète de
des enjeux alors le mieux là c'est de
rester avec ceux qui connaissent ça on
verra si le gouvernement il coûte vos
conseils on va voir l'occasion d'en
reparler merci beaucoup à tous les deux
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]